derrick school to try to control that
offense that shep just mentioned
derek is making his 14th start of the
season he's been very good lately he's
allowed three runs or less than seven
consecutive starts there's an outline
drive right at third baseman jamer
candelario knocked him to his knees
but one pitch and one hard out
are you ready for the first pitch i've
been told that so many times and it
looked like
jimmy candelario was ready
threw it over
first pitch was hit hard and we were
underway he better be ready that would
have torn his hand right off julie
guriel here's the 2-2
a chopper to second
the flip to zach short the return throw
to first and the double play converted
nice way to end the opening frame for
derek school
11 pitches and some help from his
defense jake odorizzi will be on the
mound today for houston yeah jay carter
is a 2-3 record with a four seven five
era 336 on base percentage for grossman
nine homers and 34 runs batted in 1-1
and that's hit in the air left center
fairly well going over is mccormick and
he'll run it down couple of steps from
the warning track and the inning is over
so a one two three frame for odarizi
with three fly ball outs and after one
astros nothing tigers nothing great to
see what tarek scuba is doing so far in
this game he's beneficial attacking the
strike zone a lot of contact he's only
got the one strikeout no walk so far you
may or may not like that the two strikes
another strikeout just blew that one by
toro up and away chas mccormick a
right-handed battard stands at a slight
angle the home plate 6-3 lefty glove in
front of the face gets the sign drops
the hands
into his motions swinging a miss
curveball down he's mixing all of his
pitches beautifully today third
strikeout the last four batters
high arm release like that good follow
through he doesn't pull off he goes
straight at the hitter that baby really
has some dive action that's why it's
yellow hammer city working quickly and
working ahead in the count that's
another plus for scoob to waive for
jason castro now the 2-2
he strikes out the side he is in command
his fourth strikeout ends the top of the
third back to back runners for the
astros a hit batter and a walk base is
loaded one out for carlos correa
sends one into center field altuve's at
third base but dude lines it up altuve
trying to score the throw goes to third
sac fly for carlos correa the astros on
the board one nothing correa drives in
his 49th run of the year carlos with the
home run yesterday to give the astros
the victory had a home run in game one
of the doubleheader he has had an rbi in
every game of this series
he's got in on just a little bit nice
when you have jose altuve out there
third rbi
in the last three day in the last two
days and corey he's now driven in six
runs in this series puerto ri on the
mound astros lead one nothing bottom of
the fourth here's grossman
swinging a man soda rizzy comes back to
strikeout grossman picking up his second
strikeout of the game one away in the
fourth good job of him getting back in
the count
tough pitch to handle right there 94 up
and then here's the one two
pop-up on the infield who wants it it
comes toro and comes yuli yuli will put
it away for the final out of the inning
one two three fourth for jayco to rizzy
he and the astros lead one nothing
castro now in scoring position
he struck him out scoville strikes out
houston's side for the second time
today but derek skubal strikes out the
side and gets the dangerous jose altuve
with a runner at second seventh
strikeout ends the fifth all on swinging
third strikes tigers mad bottom of the
fifth inning christian javier taking
over for jayco to rizzy oda rizzy leaves
the game after five innings and 77
pitches javier has not pitched since the
first game of this road trip now it's
jonathan scope right-handed hitter who's
over two slide out to deep center and
head into an inning ending fielder's
choice
got him
jonathan scope strikes out against
christian javier went out in the sixth
inning that's what makes his breaking
ball so much better because you have to
cheat kind of to get to his fastball
because it's harder than it looks javier
picking up a strikeout after the walk to
badoo now he'll face robbie grossman two
and two the count
swing and a miss javier strikes out back
to back hitters scoping out grossman two
away jamer candelario looking to deliver
a big two-out hit in a one-nothing game
there goes badour
yeah you're absolutely right jack by the
way badou just got a great jump right
there
he's off and running and i love the
ricky henderson first hit first slide
there
yeah this is so important here because
it's a one run game so now
a base hit something that might just
elude the infielders little blooper to
the left side maybe
can score both runners go 3-2 pitch
grounded right side altuve is there and
the inning ends with two left on base
javier battled through the sixth inning
strands a couple of runners in the
astros lead heading to the seventh one
nothing it's been a really strong outing
from derek school even though his team
trails one nothing he has been dynamite
he struck him out three pitches
all of them change ups down goes toro
for the third time today swinging just
really really well thrown two changeups
in a row he doesn't have to be perfect
with them these are not exactly down and
away they're down in the zone but
they're not down and away where you want
it
that's all pitchers by the way and right
at candelario
good recovery derek school has thrown
102 pitches today second most in his
career and he has been dynamite he's
through seven
raley inherits runners at first and
second two away and he'll face the top
of the order akil badu against lefties
just three for 27.
it's been some magic learning moments as
he drives right he drops it in there
castro stumbles around third he will
score we are tied
just what the doctor ordered for a keel
but do he gets a pitch and keeps his
hands back long enough to just throw the
barrel at it you see he was fooled a
little bit
but he pulls that ball into shallow
right field
around comes willy castro to tie the
game up what a job huh just his fourth
hit off a lefty this year we played
seven in detroit in a 1-1 game derek
school's day is done but what a day it
was for him seven innings of work he
only allowed one hit derek used all his
pitches today you see he had a career
high 21
swings and misses can't ask for more out
of the left hand ryan presley on here in
the bottom of the ninth inning now he
will pay saquil badu same up at the end
of the game yesterday
ball hit to center field straw back on
it still going back he's made a lot of
plays and center in this series and puts
another one away we head to extra inning
gregory soto remains out there for the
tigers he'll seven for 11 in the series
with a couple of stolen bases for straw
here's the 2-1 from soto on the ground
to short
zach short
takes care of it now what a job by
gregory soto
in his second inning of work he gets out
of the jam infield's gonna be pulled in
now with the runner 90 feet less than 90
feet away
he bunts it badou on the charge he is
safe and the tigers win it
on a suicide squeeze
wow
well the element of surprise is what
got the best of the houston astros there
robbie grossman lays down a perfect bunt
all he has to do is get it down the
pitcher
covers and tries to flip it home but
with the speed of akiel badou it was too
late that's a perfectly executed suicide
squeeze for the walk off in the win
great effort by both teams with a super
effort by the tigers